so tell us a little bit about yourself
Alan what do you uh what do you do I'm a
crime scene investigator oh jackpot holy
holy I love crime uh I've committed
some crimes uh and that's unfortunate
yeah well just try and catch me
um wait I just admitted you keep me
talking for five minutes you'll have
everything you need the worst criminal I
would fold so quickly oh yeah sure I
killed him yeah I just don't go looking
in the back in that shed
near the elm tree in my in my yard I
mean if you didn't say it I think Sona
would probably she would yeah yeah but
you would give details they'd never even
ask yeah exactly I would just be
immediately saying you know it's harder
to kill choke to death than you think
and
um but listen this is a serious
profession so you are a crime scene
investigator
this is I mean I have so many questions
I figured you might yeah so are you
dealing with a lot of homicides do you
go to a lot of homicide scenes wow
Kansas City we we deal with um violent
crime mostly yeah okay is it
particularly high in Kansas City
um it's been lower in the past right so
at this point
it's getting up there yeah because when
I think of Kansas City I think barbecue
first
um you must have seen some crazy stuff
just insane stuff did it take you a
while to get used to seeing people who
had violently met their end does it or
or did you quickly get used to it um I
don't think you quickly get used to it
if you quickly get used to it then maybe
um you should see someone which a lot of
people do and that's fine right that
means you're a sociopath I believe no
empathy yeah that's kind of a problem
however there is kind of a work mode
that you get into and you
compartmentalize and you say okay I'm
here to do a job and you know if if
you're conscious of it you're able to
process it at a later time and just kind
of do your job and then you know maybe
later you go home and go okay what just
happened let me try and do this in a
healthy way and not go like drink a
six-pack in the shower and cry I would
just cry I would cry all day I'd cry
when I'm working yeah you cry anyway
yeah I do and you also drink a six-pack
in the shower
you do all this and you've never seen a
dead body okay so we have to get into
the nitty-gritty here and I I don't you
know I want to be tasteful about this
but this is what you do and it
fascinates me and I Know It fascinates
Sona as well who cares how David feels
about it
um I'm sorry David you know David I Care
thank you thank you by the way we've now
determined I have no empathy so yeah and
I'm like what's the big deal it's a
bunch of dead people yeah
watch it Alan okay uh one push of a
button and then absolutely nothing
happens
um so uh okay how many what's the most
homicides that you've uh encountered in
one day I think three three in one day
and they weren't it's not like they all
shot each other these were separate uh
I was gonna say it's cheating if they
all shot each other which is right only
happens in really old movies
I've always thought in those scenes in
movies where people are holding guns
right at each other and it's supposed to
neither one will blink I think just if
one of you pulls the trigger you win
yeah yeah so what's I don't understand
those scenes but anyway I'm taking us
away from the pot of gold we have here
which is uh you come upon a homicide
scene what's the first thing that you
are looking for so we will talk to the
officers who responded they will give us
a bit of a rundown of what you know what
may have occurred because of you know
the technology today oftentimes there's
video of what happened so we'll watch
that and try and under get in get an
idea of kind of what we're looking at
and then we will walk through the scene
look and see what we have and assess
what we might need equipment wise and
all that and then we'll start taking
photographs this is true I've noticed a
lot there's video of every everything
now which completely has changed the
game I would think because more and more
crimes even if there's no video in the
home everybody's got a ring camera
people have uh you know stores any
business has a camera there's sometimes
the city itself has has put cameras
everywhere so you can see which vehicles
were in the area and right and then when
you go to Home Depot and buy the tarp
and the shovel and the duct tape that's
always a bad idea that's always a bad
idea yeah I say and Mike are you writing
this down Conan no listen oh trust me
I've thought about this one you get them
slowly over a long period of time so
um but are you ordering off of Amazon no
that's still bad no no no okay you don't
go off of Amazon you just get them very
slowly and the more that you can just
the more that you can pick up something
like you're talking to somebody or over
at their house uh they say I'm gonna go
and check on the uh the beef stew that's
simmering and you you just wander over
and you see that they've got a shovel
and you pick it up and you put in the
back of your car
you need to plan a good crime has to be
planned out maybe at least a year in
advance and you pick up things slowly
and quietly also I've had all my
fingerprints burned off I don't know if
that does anything that doesn't I know
you know what I did it and then I didn't
think about the DNA component yeah so um
you know if you if you committed the
crime uh Barefoot we could get your foot
prints as well yeah but I'm always when
I'm when I murder I'm always wearing
bright yellow Crocs but you're also very
recognizable on a camera and I feel like
if you see a camera pointed at you
you'll start performing doing it this is
a problem now and is that there'll be
footage of there's a guy in Crocs
wearing a wig and he's doing bits oh
he's doing the string Dance Now
between the string dance and he's saying
stick around there might be more murder
after these messages and then you again
I'm arrested and this is after quietly
picking up everything I needed over a
six year period yeah
sorry